the jurgen experience this is another
thing that's going on right now this is
the perfect storm
the convergence of all these different
things that are happening at the same
time
and one of them being the covid lockdown
yeah social media
the covet lockdown the polarization of
our country with
trump and then you know this this weird
thing
where everybody has to pretend that
biden isn't dying
like this is all happening together at
the same time like everyone has to
pretend
he's gonna do a great job i'm gonna vote
for him we just need to get trump out of
office like oh my god like
yeah can we freeze this yeah we freeze
this and rethink this do you guys have
anybody else on deck
no one i mean i guess harris is on she's
wearing timberlands
i guess she's one of us
i seriously loved the tweet whoever it
was it was like oh found the undercover
cop
but like anyone who sees anyone wearing
these in a club this brand new is the
undercover cop
but charlemagne party charlemagne on
instagram was like
you know because they were saying that
she's bringing back timberlands and he
was like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about like
he's a
he's in new york like dudes in new york
have been wearing timberlands forever
they've been wearing them since the 80s
or whenever they started wearing them
they never stopped
wearing them like this she's bringing
back timberlands yeah that's like some
guy saying i'm bringing back
chucks you know i'm bringing back
converse all-stars [ __ ] you you are
yeah they never went away man you can't
bring back something that never went
away
and timbaland's in new york especially
never went away
yeah you're you're not allowed to um to
go back to biden you're not allowed to
say that
you're problematic yeah i'm a problem
but i've been
getting cancelled for that for i said i
said in that column i said
something like he may or may not be
slipping into dementia i mentioned
about why i'm not voting and then
someone from the new york times said
that is a a widely debunked conspiracy
theory that he's slipping into dementia
and i said okay i said may or may not
and can you post
like cite your source for where this has
been debunked
so that my like people reading this
thread can see it
and this new york times researcher
writer says well i've seen him speaking
and that's just what i gather from like
you seeing something
debunking a situation that's not
you okay so you see something and have a
different opinion and other people have
a different opinion that's not
widely like oh well i've seen it and
that's it
could you imagine let's let's pretend
that kamala harris was the democratic
nominee
and biden was a republican could you
imagine how savage oh yeah they would be
at attacking his mental incompetence
yeah no no that's actually
a really interesting well this is not an
experiment bizarre
bias comes into play and this is where
everybody's getting gaslit
because they're pretending that
everything's okay because
all they want to do is get trump out of
office but
in doing that you're exposing this very
bizarre tendency that people have
to comply and to go along with these
lines of thinking and behaving and
talking
and i can't get into that man because
that's cult [ __ ]
yeah that's religious [ __ ] i mean that's
where these things come from they come
from everybody
not saying what they really feel because
there's an agreement
that's been made you're going to be on
the right team aren't you you're going
to do the right thing
you're going to do the right thing
aren't you yeah or we'll burn your
[ __ ] house down
sometimes we have to stop these fascists
or we'll burn your house down
some guy offered me an interview with
someone who i probably could get an
interview with him anyway
and he said if you vote for biden i will
get you this guy as an interview
come on we have to save the country what
those real message i got like hey bro
like
jamie's laughing that's so good so yeah
that's just
i understand what you're going with it's
like so crazy yeah that's [ __ ] insane
it's come on we have to save the country
are you sure what what about what about
it do you want to save the kind
what what what part is going to save
what is it what's going to happen when i
was on i did one of uh
brett's um unity campfires and oh did
you
yeah and you know i was asking i was
like everyone
is saying that the other side is the
existential threat
and then brett was kind of like well we
need to come together because
this that is the existential threat but
everyone but isn't that
i'm like why is everyone on flight 93
you know like
everyone's scared of course but it's
also
i i guess maybe i have optimistic
faith in america like i don't really see
how
trump or biden like
how can me i don't know i i don't know i
hope
that either one of them can't destroy
america in four years because that means
america's already [ __ ] yeah
well we're kind of [ __ ] i don't like
saying
i know my my 16 year old nephew and all
his friends listen and
i don't want to give these children no
hope for the future they have hope for
the future but we're [ __ ] do they
yeah we do yeah yeah listen we're not in
the
[ __ ] dark ages no the mongols aren't
coming over the hills with horses and
flaming
arrows that's what i always say we're
like people are like there's a civil war
i'm like where do
americans do fat for civil war who's
who's fighting what does that even look
like
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love